cities now are developing in ways that
are quite different from cities of 100
and 200 years ago cities are growing at
an incredibly fast rate 50 years ago we
had two mega cities of 10 million and
right now we have 19 mega cities and
another 30 years are adding about
another 10 mega cities so the rate at
which these cities are forming is very
fast it's unprecedented not only are
these cities developing on primary
cultural land but they're also expanding
into forests and wetlands and other
natural ecosystems the development of
these cities completely changes and
modifies the local hydrology and the
local land cover which has huge
implications for things like regional
and local climate Karen Seto is an
associate professor in the urban
environment at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies her
research has revealed that cities are
not only affected by their environment
they shape it Shenzhen is interesting in
part because it is the place that the
Chinese government focused on as the
laboratory for economic policies and so
Shenzhen was the first special economic
zone in all of China and what that means
is in the late 1970s the central
government of China identified Schengen
as a place where it would test
market-based policies so over 30 years
the population of the Pearl River Delta
has really exploded Shenzhen has gone
from a small fishing village to one of
the global manufacturing hubs and
certainly one of the major manufacturing
hubs of China and the population of the
Pearl River Delta has gone from about 8
million in the early 70s in 1973 to more
than 50 million today soaring
skyscrapers are not only changing their
surroundings they're changing the
climate cities are definitely affecting
their local climate research on this has
actually shown that cities have a big
impact on their local
climate through the materials that are
used in cities the use of different
materials whether it's concrete the loss
of educated qualities the loss of
vegetative cover completely transforms
the local hydrology and the local
climate system cities are shaping their
environment and shaping their climate
and I think one of the big unknowns as
we under the twenty-first century is on
the whole how will cities not only
change their local climate both in terms
of precipitation and temperature but how
will many cities actually affect more
regional and even global climate
worldwide cities are expected to absorb
2 billion more people by 2030
professor Seto believes environmental
sustainability is crucial to urban
design there's a huge challenge ahead in
terms of providing infrastructure energy
water sanitation for all of these new
urban dwellers and at the same time
there's a huge opportunity as well in
terms of developing these cities in a
much more sustainable way so it clearly
if we look at globally most of the co2
emissions worldwide come from cities and
come from urban activities most of the
world's agricultural production goes to
feed people in urban areas and people in
cities car production transportation
energy demand is why people in cities so
we change the way we develop cities so
that people can walk around for their
needs and they don't have to drive there
actually will have a huge impact
potentially on energy demand
infrastructure demand water needs energy
needs while professor sito's research
establishes that mega cities are
modifying their own environment more
research is needed to determine what
role global climate change is playing in
the process and so we need significantly
more research to try to understand how
as cities expand how do they affect
temperature how do they affect
precipitation do cities induce rainfall
to cities create drier in climates and
how does that interact with global
patterns of
climate change so on the one hand you
have global climate change happening and
you have cities modifying their own
climates and there's very little
understanding about how these two
interact so I think that's an area where
we need a lot more research and it's
very very important for more information
about the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies visit environment
Yale edu
you